Beauty is in the eye of the beholder - but
since our survival is largely driven by sexual
selection, we often attempt to accentuate
our features with makeup. So what exactly
is in makeup products, and should we trust
these substances that we apply to our bodies?
Could makeup actually be bad for you?
Historically, ancient Egyptians would grind
up a mineral substance containing primarily
lead sulfide to rim around their eyes, creating
the sultry cleopatra look. Little did they
know that lead is a potent neurotoxin, which
can lead to learning and behavioural difficulties
in children and decrease fertility in both
men and women. Later, In 1891, creams, lotions,
and blush containing compounds of the radioactive
element radium were also sold to women in
Europe, promising a youthful glow - until
the harmful effects of exposure to radioactivity
was discovered, that is.
But makeup has come a long way, and now there
are only trace amounts of lead found in our
products. Lead is found in nature and is therefore
an unintentional contaminant from the manufacturing
process. An FDA study of 400 tubes of lipstick
found concentrations ranged from 0.026ppm
to 7.19ppm of lead, which is under Health
Canada's limits of 10ppm.
Lipstick is about 47% oils, 36% pigments,
17% waxes and 5% other components including
preservatives. The oils are primarily castor
oils, extracted from a bean which contains
the protein ricin – one of the most toxic
substances on this planet which has been used
as a biological weapon. However, the process
of extracting castor oil involves heating,
thereby denaturing ricin and rendering it
inactive.
Pigments now use synthetic dyes due to cost
and production efficiencies, although traditionally,
red pigments were extracted from dried and
crushed cochineal insects. Some blue pigments
are created with ferric ferrocyanide. Cyanide
is extremely deadly, however in this compound
structure, cyanide has a very strong bond
to iron. As a result, it is unable to come
apart to poison us by eye shadow.
When it comes to mascara, we recommend tossing
the tube after three months of opening. Harmful
bacteria of the Streptococcus species and
certain fungi were discovered thriving in
36.4% of mascara tubes. And this is especially
important for contact lens wearers, as bacteria
can easily enter the micro abrasions caused
by the lens itself.
Parabens have been a big concern as well as
they’re in a myriad of cosmetic products.
Paraben works by mimicking estrogen and binding
to estrogen receptors. This can cause the
expression of genes to be changed and communication
within cells to be altered. Additionally,
it can lead to the growth of certain breast
cancer cells. However, many products are switching
to paraben free - and a lot of research still
needs to be done in order to reach any definitive
conclusions.